bonjour et bienvenue pour cette édition
du vendredi du journal de la rédaction
dans quelques jours la semaine
européenne de la mobilité va nous
inciter à nous déplacer autrement invité
Muriel Laroui chargé d'études transport
en commun pour la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline Philippe leguer boucher
charcutia Chevreuse a rejoint confrérie
des Compagnons du Goût qui regroupe les
meilleurs professionnels c'est le 9e
artisan évelinois distingué rentrée des
classes nouveau rythme scolaire
remanimement du gouvernement retour de
Benoît amont au poste de député nous
reviendrons aussi sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine c'est un choc
pour l'hôpital de pédiatrie et de
rééducation de bulion sa directrice a
été placée mardi en garde à vue pendant
près de 20h CIN plaintes pour
harcèlement moral ont été déposé à son
encontre par des employés les gendarmes
auraient également enregistré 45
témoignages de salariés de
l'établissement
le parquet de Versailles poursuit pour
l'instant ses investigations sans que
l'on sache la suite qui sera donnée à ce
dossier invité de cette édition du 5
septembre Muriel Laroui bonjour et
bienvenue en plateau chargé d'études
transport en commun pour la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans en yeline nous
faire oublier la voiture c'est l'enjeu
de cette semaine de la mobilité semaine
européenne qui débutera le 16 septembre
prochain comment avez-vous réorganiser
organiser vos services mobiliser vos
services pour cet événement il y aura
beaucoup d'animations pour les parties
particulier et pour les entreprises
alors comme tous les ans on sera présent
dans les entreprises nous serons présent
dans 13 entreprises cinquantinoises ça
permet de toucher une partie des 108000
salariés de l'agglomération on sera
aussi présent pour le grand public le
samedi 20 septembre devant le Vélodrome
pour des animations vélo
euh nous sommes également au côté des
différentes des différents volontaires
qui vont se passer de voiture pendant 2
semaines des vrais on justement
peut-être plus en détail de de ce projet
vous avez mis en place un projet qui va
permettre à une poignée de de personnes
de tester la vie vraiment la vie du
quotidien sans voiture voilà nous avons
lancé un défi aux salariés et aux
habitants de cquantin en Yveline on a
fait un appel à volontaire et nous en
avons retenu huit qui pendant 2 semaines
du 15 septembre au 26 septembre vont se
passer de voiture nous leur fournissons
grâce à des partenaires différents
moyens de transport pass Navigo pour
ceux qui feront train plus bus ticketé
plus par skibus euh pour ceux qui feront
du bus ceux qui seront à vélo on
possibilité d'avoir des vélos assistance
électrique par deux et trois roues une
entreprise de voisin voilà vous allez
les les surveiller si voir si il jouent
vraiment le jeu vous allez prendre le
clé de voiture non non l'objectif
véritablement c'est de leur de les aider
à relever le défi ils se sont inscrits
ils se disent que c'est peut-être
possible et ils vont essayer eu certains
ont déjà organisé la garde des enfants
en fonction de leur nouveau mode de
déplacement d'autres se lancent sans
grande organisation en disant bon on
t'atonne on va essayer voilà voilà
l'idée c'est vraiment de montrer que
c'est possible et de donner l'occasion
aux gens de tester ça ce sera le fil
rouge pour cette semaine de la mobilité
il y a aussi des événements ponctuels le
grand rendez-vous le rendez-vous
principal c'est le 20 le vin on vous
donne rendez-vous au Vélodrome vous
aurez possibilité d'essayer des vélos
assistance électrique et possibilité
d'essayer des Vél délire pour avancer en
marche arrière pédaler avec vos bras
vous avez possibilité aussi de faire
marquer votre vélo contre le vol le jour
où malencontreusement quelqu'un vous
déroberez votre
si la peut main DESS elle peut vousacter
grâce à un numéro d'identification vous
pouvez aussi faire réparer gratuitement
votre vélo devant le vélodrome de 14h à
18h plein d'informations transport
également nous serons là pour répondre
aux questions en direct programme
complet sur le site internet de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quanttin on parlait de de changer
les mentalités voir un peu comment les
gens pouvaient avoir le le déclic
comment nous pouvions avoir le déclic
pour changer véritablement de vie sans
voiture quelles sont vos habitudes de de
déplacement seriez-vous prêt à a changé
de mode de vie c'est notre question du
jour nous sommes allés vous la poser
dans les rues de saint-qutin ben moi
j'habite Boulogne alors je me déplace en
de roues en voiture d'accord parce qu'il
y a pas de transport en commun Boulogne
voisin de bretonnais d'accord oh par le
bus c'est pas mal des services 50 an en
vine on peut aller à versaill avec un
ticket de 1,30 € ah le train ouais bah
ouais parce que on est tranquille assis
voilà donc je lis je fais tous mes trucs
écoutz beaucoup en voiture et puis de
temps en temps à vélo quand c'est pas
trop loin en transport en commun à pied
bus
train tram aussi si on prend la voiture
on n'est pas sûr d'arriver à une heure
fixe et puis il y a aussi le fait que la
carte orange soit remboursée à 100 % par
le par l'employeur donc voilà la
motivation est est différente
quelquefois on se rend compte de
l'environnement du de l'enjeu
environnemental pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
puis par contre le déclencheur c'est
souvent le porte-monnaie ça coûte moins
cher d'utiliser le vélo c'est pas tant
le porte-monnaie les gens vont choisir
le mode le plus adapté et le plus
pratique euh l'aspect coût viendra après
euh vous aurez beau dire la personne que
c'est cher d'utiliser sa voiture si
c'est le mode le plus adapté le plus
pratique elle utilisera sa voiture par
contre il y a énormément de déplacements
qu'elle pourrait être amené à faire
autrement et c'est ça aussi qui est
important la majorité des déplacements
font moins de 3 km moins de 3 km ça se
fait à vélo et c'est quand même le mode
le plus pratique et le plus efficace en
plus pour ces déplacements et vélo c'est
ce que vous utilisez parce que vous me
l'avez dit avant qu'on commence ce
journal vous avez organisé votre vie en
fonction du des déplacements c'est ça je
ne voulais plus avoir à faire des temps
de trajet trop importants en voiture ou
en transport en commun et donc j'ai
déménagé pour pouvoir me déplacer
uniquement à vélo ou quasiment
uniquement en vélo l'idée de cette
semaine c'est de faire disparaître
complètement la voiture absolument pas
dans votre garderobe vous n'avez pas que
des baskets vous n'avez pas non plus que
des chaussures à talon l'idée c'est
d'avoir de mettre à disposition des des
habitants un cocktail de déplacement
c'est-à-dire qu'ils puissent avoir le
mode le plus adapté au moment où ils en
ont besoin à pouvoir utiliser un taxi le
jour où il y a besoin de prendre un taxi
le pouvoir prendre un bus le jour où
c'est le bus le plus adapté le vélo mais
aussi la voiture on a des parcs relés
par exemple qui permett aux gens de se
rabattre en gare de Saint-Quentin et
dans les gardes de l'agglomération de
laisser leur voiture en toute sécurité
et ensuite bah d'utiliser normalement
les transports en commun le vélo bien
évidemment c'est aussi un loisir il y a
des balades qui seront proposé pendant
cette semaine de la mobile ité si on
peut en dire brièvement un mot et aussi
je vous renvoie vers le site de la Glo
pour le programmeors le vélo est est un
des fils conducteurs sur l'ensemble de
la semaine aussi bien en entreprise
puisque les entreprises VT proposer des
réparations de vélo sur les sites des
essais de vélo à science électrique et
le samedi l'Office de Tourisme à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine et
de la semaine de la mobilité propose un
certain nombre d'itinéraires et de
découvert du territoire à vélo la
semaine de la mobilité semaine
européenne existe depuis 2002 on peut en
faire un bilan ça fonctionne les
mentalités évolue les mentalités
évoluent ça le le la voiture devient un
vrai sujet on commence à parler du coût
de la voiture les vélos le vélo devient
vrai mode et n'est plus seulement
associé à du loisir ou à des olib britus
qui montrer sur un de roues ça commence
à devenir un mode noble sur lequel les
entreprises s'investissent dans lequel
les partenaires sociaux
également bon faut savoir quand même que
le premier frein à l'usage du vélo c'est
le stationnement à domicile donc il y a
énormément de partenairire à mobiliser
pour arriver à développer le
stationnement du vélo ensuite il faut la
réparation nous avons la chance sur
Saint-Quentin d'avoir plusieurs
entreprise qui répar les vélos c'est pas
toujours le cas sur le tissu habitat
dans d'autres départements euh après il
y a plus d'excuses on pourz faire du
vélo on va tous s'y mettre et moi aussi
merci beaucoup mriel Laroui semaine de
la mobilité du 16 au 22 septembre en
Europe et puis à Saint-Quentin en
Eveline évidemment on en reparlera lors
des prochaines éditions du journal merci
à vous on va continuer à évoquer
l'actualité de ce vendredi avant de
revenir tout à l'heure sur les moments
forts de cette semaine écoulée et cette
nouvelle prouesse de Carmat la société
yvelinis a se basé à véisie elle qui
avait produit le premier cœur artificiel
vient de réitérer son essai clinique une
bioprothèse de haute technologie a été
implanté sur un patient au centre
hospitalier universitaire de Nantes il y
a quelques semaines 8 mois après une
première implantation réalisée à Paris
rapporte Libération et France interre
pour l'heure l'identité du patient reste
secrète en mars dernier le premier
patient qui avait bénéficié de ce cœur
artificiel était décédé la société
évelinoise côté en bourse avait alors
précisé qu'elle maintenait son programme
d'essès comprenant notamment quatre
implantations en tout elle avait obtenu
l'autorisation pour cela le 16 juillet
dernier en
1997 un groupement des Compagnons du
Goût a vu le jour il fédère depuis les
meilleurs bouchers et charcutiers
traiteur de France 350 artisans parmi
lesquels Philippe leguer c'est le 9e
représentant des Yvelines le premier de
Chevreuse Floran parfait et Claire
Cambier pour ce reportage
combien vous prendriez qu' vendredi ou
samedi donc si je vois ça vous mett de
côté vous inquz pas attentif à centèle
Philippe leuger depuis 23 ans intronisé
aujourd'hui compagnon du goût il intègre
une confrie créé il y a plus de 20 ans
le de compagnon duû nous apporte une
reconnaissance par rapport à la
clientèle et après bien s que
économiement c'est très très intéressant
aperçoit 2 3 mois après oui ça c'est
très rapide pour l'occasion la
confrériie a fait le déplacement
célébrer l'événement et faire découvrir
les produit que seuls les Compagnons du
Goût sont habilités à faire un moyen de
mettre en valeur auprès du public ses
artisans fortement concurrencés par la
grande
distribution on peut demander ce qu'on
veut le morceau qu'on veut la taille
qu'on veut c'est ça qui est intéressant
dans une petite boutique parce qu'on n
pas forcément besoin de tout ce qui nous
donne dans les supermarchés je trouve
que c'est très très important que les
gens soient pointus dans leur métier
alors ça pour moi c'est très important
un artisan est un artisan Philippe
lauger obtient cette distinction pour la
deuxème fois il avait déjà obtenu il y a
7 ans à rembouillé mais a dû proposer à
nouveau sa candidature lorsqu'il a
repris la boucherie de Chevreuse la
sélection est rigoureuse 500 bouchers
charcutiers bénéficie du titre de
Compagnon du goût sur toute la France et
neuf dans les ivelines nous ce qu'on re
cherche c'est que chaque compagon du goû
soit absolument pareil c'est un accueil
un savoir-faire et un professionnalisme
une qualité de produits ça soit dans la
viande ou dans la charcuterie et puis
surtout une hygiène irréprochable une
boutique doit être bien tenue du matin à
l'ouverture jusqu'au soir dans la soirée
à la fermeture ça doêre absolument
nickel beaucoup de travail pour cet
artisan il est le dernier boucher de
Chevreuse la ville en comptait encore 4
il y a quelques
années un mot de culture le vélodrome
national annonce la tenue de son premier
festival dédié au hip hop le label Juste
Debout la manufacture 11 sont associé à
ce projet assez ambitieux des artistes
internationaux seront présents t force
et son nom proposera le 27 septembre et
pendant 24 heures des démonstrations de
danse des concerts des performances de
DJ pour les amateurs DMX mop exhibit
Beal du groupe Cypress il sont annoncés
il vous en coûtera 37 € si vous réservé
avant ce dimanche 39 € à partir du lundi
8 septembre il vous reste à peine 48 he
voici un avant-goût
et puis on n'oublie pas he qu'à partir
du 18 février prochain le vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin va accueillir
du sport une semaine de championnat du
monde de cyclisme sur piste le complexe
sportif situé à montiny le Bretonneux
était en compétition avec
aguaskaalientes au Mexique il a été
choisi par l'Union Cycliste
Internationale 5000 spectateurs qui vont
pouvoir soutenir les coureurs de
l'équipe de France sur une piste flamban
neuve de 250
m après ce point sur l'actualité du jour
l'actualité du vendredi on en revient à
présent sur le reste de l'actualité de
la semaine vous en avez l'habitude les
nouveaux rythmes scolaires qui sont
lancés en cette rentrée afin de
favoriser des temps d'enseignement plus
efficaces les horaires ont été revus en
fonction des villes le changement est
accueilli plus ou moins bien par les
familles nous sommes allés à leur
rencontre ce mercredi dans les communes
de plaisir et de r Bouillet là où la
journée d'école se termine à 11h54 très
précisément et certains parents sont
assez perplexes par cet horaire c'est
assez étonnant après que ce soit bon
11h54 ou midi ça ne change pas
grand-chose voilà il en a été décidé
comme ça c'est étonnant mais bon j'ai
pas très bien compris le
11h54 puis ça fait déjà des grosses
journées ça déjà 3h le matin là ça leur
fait une demi-heure de plus ce que ça
change pour moi déjà c'est surtout au
niveau des enfants de l'élever 5 jours
de suite par semaine c'est toute une
réorganisation je trouve que c'est pas
très bien parce que le mercredi c'est
une pause pour la semaine donc voilà bah
déjà F F pour moi c'est déjà il y a plus
d'école c'est bien et en même temps
c'est un peu embêtant voilà parce que
vous plus faire
d'activités c'est très c'est quelques
réactions le journal qui se poursuit les
tap ou tap c'est l'autre versant du
réaménagement des horaires d'école ces
moments dégagés dans la journée pour
permettre aux élèves de pratiquer un
sport un loisir ou de travailler des
leçons avec avec des animateurs
normalement compétents les villes sont
libres de proposer à des activités de
leur choix certaines font même du Zè
pour d'autres en revanche chees services
minimum les mare UMP d'élancour et de
plaisir sont très opposés à cette
réforme il parle d'ailleurs d'un temps
de récréation supplémentaire mettre en
place des animations coûtent cher selon
leurs propos le maire d'élancour
maintient la pression il parle d'une
mobilisation dans une quinzaine de jours
de son collectif antiréforme composé de
700 élus cette réforme un milliard elle
va coûter au pays si vous faites rien en
plus de la garderie et si vous faites
quelque chose coûter 2 milliards donc
entre 1 et 2 milliards on n'a pas les
moyens aujourd'hui avec la la baisse des
moyens la baisse des dépenses publiques
de de de soutenir une réforme en plus
qui n'a absolument pas fait ses preuves
nous demanderons de toute façon la
suspension de cette réforme soit sous la
forme d'un moratoire soit sous la forme
du ce qu'on appelle le libre choix c'est
que les maires quand envie d'y aller bah
on le on le redemandera sinon on on
proposera une grve générale obliger un
maire à prendre à prendre des risques et
engager sa responsabilité sans lui don
donner les moyens sans lui donner les
effectifs et sans lui donner en plus le
contenu pédagogique parce que vous
remarquez il y aurait eu un contenu
pédagogique homologué par éducation
quand même c'est à nous de d'inventer
maintenant alors bon moi la limite j'ai
des tablettes j'ai j'ai une
infrastructure assez assez importante
mais le maire qui connait pas
l'éducation nationale sais pas qui était
médecin qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'il
qu'il se metent à créer du contenu
pédagogique donc c'est c'est insensé
cette réforme mais si demmer s'oppose
encore à cette réforme dans le
département aucun en revanche empêcher
l'accès des enseignants à l'école
mercredi matin à la e de ce qui s'est
produit dans les son par exemple le
directeur académique des services de
l'éducation nationale dans les ivelines
a cependant répondu sur ce plateau au
maire d'élancour on
l'écoute je me souviens que la mairie
d'élancour souhaitait développer des
activités numériques autour du numérique
entre midi et 2 et peut-être le soir
donc bon les activités sont peut-être
pas montables tout de suite dans le
contexte dans lequel se situe la commune
mais il y a bon espoir que ces temps
peut-être bougeent et puis soit occupé
de manière nouvelle Jean-Michel qui a
également réagi aux déclarations du
directeur allemand de l'éducation de
l'Organisation de coopération et de
développement économique l'OCDE pour qui
l'école française est l'une des plus
inégalitaires au monde le classement
édité par l'OCDE évalue le niveau des
élèves de 15 ans de 65 pays le fameux
classement PISA qui fait souvent parler
et la France y figure à la 25e place
faut pas oublier tous les efforts qui
sont faits est-ce qu'on jugule malgré
tout du point de vue des inégalités là
l'espoir qu'on a avec les nouveaux
dispositifs de ces dernières années hein
qui en fait remontent au-delà de de
2010-22 certaines choses ont été essayé
dans les années 90 dans l'éducation
prière prioritaire ce qu'on espère c'est
vraiment appuyer là où on sait qu'on a
du résultat supplémentaire les mises en
groupe plus petit ce sont les
dispositifs plus de maîtres que de
classe dans certaines écoles la prise en
charge beaucoup plus tôt et de manière
appropriés des moins de 3 ans et puis un
certain nombre d'autres facteurs qui
vont faire que les enseignants vont y
rester un peu plus longtemps
et puis qu'on acquire les fondamentaux
de manière plus efficace donc voilà
c'est pas du jour au lendemain que
peut-être PISA mettra la France au
topance mais la conscience de ce
problème dans le pays grandit et les
efforts historiques qui sont faits
doivent nous permettre de de gagner du
terrain et parmi les moyens qui sont
déployés pour l'éducation une nouvelle
méthode de formation pour les
professeurs stagiaires et cette semaine
vous avez découvert sur notre antenne
Emmanuel elle pour la première fois
c'est à Montin le bretonux elle est
revenue pour nous sur son tout premier
jour
d'école la rentrée scolaire a sonné ce
matin ils étaient
302624 enfants à retrouver les bancs de
l'école dans le département un grand
jour pour tous les écolier mais aussi
pour Emmanuel de Lorge elle entame sa
première année en tant que professeur
des écoles à l'établissement Marie Noël
de Montin est-ce qu'elle va étude
non pas ce soir d'accord tu peux
t'asseoir il y a le plan de classe qui
affiche au tableau Emmanuel aura à sa
charge 25 élèves de CM2 cette année elle
est encore stagiaire son temps sera
réparti entre l'enseignement et une
formation universitaire le reste de la
semaine les enfants auront classe avec
Valérie Lopez la directrice donc je suis
quand même dans l'école madame de Lorge
prend ma suite le jeudi et le vendredi
et on fera un mercredi sur deux
aujourd'hui elle donne cours
exceptionnellement à deux Elena une
assistante de vie scolaire les épulera
également au quotidien elle aura à sa
charge deux enfants avec un handicap lég
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment très bien qui
est quelqu'un pour les accompagner pour
les aider à écrire à comprendre des
choses pour voir pour qu'il puisse
participer vraiment dans la classe comme
les autres ce matin la classe a fait
connaissance un premier échange réussi
pour Emmanuel c'est le début d'une
carrière synonyme de passion ce que
j'aimis dans ce métier c'est vraiment le
contact avec les enfants j'aime leur
spontanéité ils sont enfin je les trouve
assez motivé par rapport on va dire aux
plus grands souvent qui sont en collège
lycée euh voilà sinon j'ai metis plein
de choses dans la vie j'aimais tout ce
qui se qui touche à la psychologie
j'aimais les langues étrangères j'aimais
la lecture voilà j'adorais aussi les
enfants bien sûr et j'ai trouvé que ce
métier regroupa un petit peu tout vous
prenez vos affaires le baptême du feu
est passé Emmanuel entame aujourd'hui sa
vie
d'enseignante cette semaine a aussi été
marquée par une forte agitation
politique après le remanimement benoî
mon s'apprête à retrouvé son poste de
député desvelin et comme le son
suppléant il est très CR envers le
gouvernement Jean-Philippe met était sur
ce plateau et lui qui n'était d'ailleurs
pas à l'université de La Rochelle de son
parti est-ce que la politique menée
aujourd'hui par François Hollande est
celle qui qu' l'a annoncé avant les les
élections présidentielles en tout cas
c'est pas le sentiment que vous vous en
avez non vous avez le sentiment d'être
trahi en tant que socialiste aussi trahi
c'est c'est c'est beaucoup dire en tous
les cas la musique que que nous
entendons de la part de l'exécutif
aujourd'hui mais n'est pas tout à fait
la même que celle que nous a proposé le
le président le président François
Hollande je m'en orgueillis de ne pas
avoir voté d'avoir fait partie la
minorité de députés socialistes qui
début octobre
2012 n'a pas voté le traité budgétaire
européen qui normalement aurait dû être
la mire de toutes les batailles ce que
l'on on on vit depuis quand même 2 ans
mais ça remonte à à loin peut-être à
2005 rappelez-vous le référendum sur sur
l'Europe c'est que quand même au sein du
Parti
socialiste mais de la même façon au sein
de l'UMP vous vous avez des des
responsables qui pensent des choses
radicalement différents différentes sur
des sujets très importants effectivement
peut-être que les clivage ne passe pas
là où il devrait passer donc il va y
avoir une réflexion politique collective
qui va être menée effectivement au sein
de de la gauche en ce qui vous concerne
aussi personnellement bien sûr
Jean-Philippe my qui laissera sa place
de député à Benoît amont à la fin du
mois de septembre politique toujours
face aux incivilités aux violences àain
agage le maire communiste de la verrière
demande une nouvelle fois un
renforcement de la présence policière
dans certains quartiers mais aussi des
moyens à l'état pour mener à bien une
politique sociale il évoque un climat
difficile un système de
vidéosurveillance va être développé dès
le mois
d'octobre il est vrai que nous faisons
partie des communes et des collectivités
qui réclamont effectivement les moyens
de police nécess aujourd'hui vous avez
quel moyens de police alors nous navons
pas les moyens de police c'est
évidemment le commissariat des lcours
qui couvre notre commune moi j'aimerais
bien que le commissariat des lcour soit
renforcé en en effectif il l'a déjà été
mais je pense qu'il y a encore des
choses à faire de manière à ce que le
travail efficace he que nous conduisons
avec le commissaire de police on se voit
régulièrement nous coordonnons nos
actions nous avons un CLSPD un des plus
actifs du département nous le réunissons
encore dans 15 jours donc nous avons un
vrai travail de concertation mais face
aux problématiques aujourd'hui lié à la
tranquillité il faut plus de moyen une
meilleure coordination et effectivement
un travail en amont un travail social
auprès des populations les plus en
difficulté puisque l'on parle de la
verrière sachez que le ponchouleur qui
enjambble la National 10 en direction de
morpa va enfin être élargie avec deux
voix supplémentaires une réunion a eu
lieu cette semaine à morpa reportage à
revoir sur notre site internet prochaine
réunion programmée le 11 septembre à La
Verrière dans la salle du scarabé en
sport l'actualité de la semaine c'est le
versaillais Thomas Barou devenu
vicechampion du monde du de s barreur
poils léger assisté du liyonnais
Augustin mouterde il représente les
couleurs du Cercle Nautique de versaill
cette ivelinois Anthony Resche l'a
rencontré son interview complète sera à
découvrir lundi à 18h30 dans le 78 sport
qui fera pour l'occasion sa grande
rentrée voici déjà un extrait de cet
entretien effectivement c'est une
première médaille au championnat du
monde c'est pas une première médaille
mondiale parce que j'ai déjà une
médaille en Coupe du monde mais c'est
une première médaille au championnat du
monde donc ouais c'est on va dire la la
concrétisation de de tout le travail qui
a été accompli depuis maintenant 5 ans
au haut niveau et c'est vrai qu'elle a
un peu tardé à venir mais on l'apprécie
d'autant plus on savait qu'ils étaient
forts on était un peu sur la retenue en
terme de pronostic on savait qu'on
pouvait être dans le coup mais que on
voilà on était pas sûr d'aller faire une
médaille en partant à Amsterdam vous
finissez 2è derrière les Suisses qui
battent le record du monde et vous-même
tous les deux vous faites la deuxième
performance mondiale de tous les temps
donc le précédent record du monde que
vous avez battu c'est quand même déjà
exceptionnel ça ou so c'est c'est vrai
que c'est vraiment le signe que la
performance des deux bateaux est est
très bonne et pas c'est pas un
championnat du monde hor rendez-vous
donc lundi 18h30 pour la première
diffusion en inégralité de ce cet
entretien avec Anthony reche et puis
nous finissons ce journal avec une
pensée toute particulière pour nos
confrères de téesson la télévision
locale de lesson son conseil
d'administration réuni ce jeudi à décid
la dissolution de la chaîne malgré une
souscription lancée au mois de juillet
il manquait 500000 € pour clore le
budget la chaîne espère obtenir un
surcis jusqu'à la fin du mois de
décembre elle espérait pouvoir déposer
un dossier pour l'obsttention d'une
l'obtention d'une fréquence sur la TNT
régionale la tson devrait néanmoinsess
des mettre à la fin de ce mois c'est une
disparition de plus dans le paysage
audiovisuel des télévisions locales
après les chaînes de Dijon ou encore de
Clermont et c'est évidemment une perte
pour la pluralité de l'information
prochaine édition du journal lundi 18h
d'ici là vous avez rendez-vous sur TVfil
78 avec yolen torrz le 78 weekend pour
faire le point sur vos prochaines
sorties loisirs et Sportiv à
lundi